Theresa went skydiving the graph below
describes Theresa's height measured in
meters as a function of time measured in
seconds so let's look at this graph over
here it's actually quite large so let me
zoom out a little bit and we can see
that at time zero her height is 700
meters and then as time increases as we
move to the right her height is
decreasing and her height is decreasing
it faster and faster rates as we move to
the right so her the rate of decline of
her height is quite steep as we approach
10 seconds after she jumps and then we
can see all of a sudden then all we can
see all of a sudden her rate of decline
slows down she's still declining as we
move forward in time but she's declining
at a slower rate and so or you could say
she's declining at 8 or she is her
height is changing at a less negative
rate it's it's quite a negative rate
right over here it seems roughly a
fairly negative rate but then it becomes
a less negative rate right over here her
height is changing at a less negative
rate and it makes sense that this is
when she deploys the parachute so after
10 seconds she deploys the parachute so
she dumps at 0 seconds 10 seconds she
deploys the parachute all right but
let's see what they are asking actually
asking us they say complete the
following sentence between 3 seconds and
8 seconds after Theresa jumped her
height decreased on average by
approximately blank meters per second so
between 3 seconds and 8 seconds so at 3
seconds so the time is 3 right over
there so let's see what H of 3 is what
is her height at 3 seconds and I'm just
looking at a graph so I'm gonna have to
Ballpark it so at 3 seconds at three
seconds her height looks pretty close
it's pretty close we just have to
approximate it so her height at the
height after 3 seconds looks like it's
about halfway between 600 and 700 so it
looks like it's about 650 meters and
then we care between 3 seconds and 8
seconds so our height at 8 seconds let's
look at that at 8 seconds
let's see this looks about
halfway it looks about halfway between
350 between 350 and 400 so I'll say her
height at 8 seconds actually since I'm
approximating it let me put a little
squiggly equal sign here her height
after 8 seconds looks like it's
approximately 300 and looks
approximately 375 meters 375 meters so
what is her average rate of change her
height decreased on average by
approximately so what we want to do is
we want to figure out the average rate
of change which you could view as the
slope of the line that connects these
two points the slope of this line is
gonna be her average rate of change so
let's think about that her average rate
of change her change in height over the
change in time for that interval
well her change in height after at 8
seconds she is at let me write it this
way her height at 8 seconds - her height
at 3 seconds so this is going to be her
change in height and the change in time
is 8 seconds she finishes at 8 seconds -
where she started or the interval that
we care about starting at 3 seconds and
so H of 8 we already said this is
approximately 375 H of 3 this is 650 and
then of course 8 minus 3 is going to be
equal to 5 I just want emphasize this is
just her average rate of change for
approximate average rate of change over
this interval as we as we go from 3 to 8
seconds our height goes from H of 3 to H
of 8 so this is going to be let's see
375 - 650
let's see if it was 375 - 675 it would
be negative 300 and so this is going to
be but then we're not subtracting 675
we're subtracting 650 so it's going to
be 25 it's going to be 25 more so this
is going to be negative 275 over 5 let
me make sure I did that math right let
me make sure I did that math right so
it's 375 - 650 is
negative 275 does that make sense
let's see 275 plus 375 would be 2 650
yeah that is right all right so let's
just figure out what this is so 5 I'll
just figure out what 5 goes into 275 and
then we can remember the negative 5 goes
into 27 5 times 5 times 5 is 25
subtract we got a to bring down a 5 5
goes into 25 five times and then we're
not going to have a remainder so this is
going to be equal to negative 55
negative 55 and the unit's her height is
given in meters so this part up here
this is in meters up here meters per
second so her change in height her
average change in height over or the
average rate of change of height over
this five seconds over this five seconds
is negative 55 meters per second one way
to think about it the slope right over
the year the slope is equal to negative
55 now it might be tempting to just
write negative 55 right over here but
let's just think about whether that
would be right between three seconds and
eight seconds after Teresa jumped her
height decreased on average by
approximately negative 55 meters per
second and decrease is important because
they're already saying that it's
decreased when this negative is telling
us that we're decreasing we're
decreasing at a rate of 55 meters per
second our average rate of change is a
decrease our average rate of high a
change of height over time is a decrease
of 55 meters per second well the
negative is already saying the decrease
so we're not decreasing at a negative
rate of change we would be decreasing at
55 meters per second so let me just
write it 55 meters per second if they
asked if they asked her height if we
asked her height if they asked the
average change of height the average
rate of change let me write this the
average rate of change of change of h
over or let me say of H from 3 seconds 3
seconds
to 8 seconds
well now this would be negative 55
meters per second but when they're
saying that her height decreased that's
re taking the negative into
consideration they're saying it's
definitely decreasing that's what the
negatives already telling us it's
decreasing by a rate of 55 meters per
second hopefully that makes some sense